شكرا للزميل نايف اعزائي المشاهدين اسعد
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مستمرون في تغطيتنا
للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في السودان تدور
مواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع في محيط
مقر القياده العامه والقصر الرئاسي
بالخرطوم وام درمان هذا ويعاني السودانيون
من تداعيات المواجهات منذ 12 يوما حيث
اغلقت المحال التجاريه في وقت يعاني
السكان من ازمات في المياه والكهرباء
وتوفير الوقود
[موسيقى]
وقف
مواطنين مسالمين دارين ياكلوا لقمه الايش
المشكله بقى خطير علينا
[موسيقى]
الناس المساجين
اليوم باليوم وانت يا النفرين انا داري
منكم بس تهزوا
[موسيقى]
هذا واعلن الجيش السوداني التصدي لهجوم
لقوات الدعم السريع على مقر القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم وقال
الجيش انه كبد قوات الدعم السريع خسائر
فادحه بحسب البيان واتهم الجيش قوات الدعم
السريع بمواصله خرق الهدنه المعلنه
[تصفيق]
ماشيين الهجوم
المواطنين ماشيين ماشيين قال لهم المخازن
المواطنين العاديين دارين يمشوا ياخذوا
لهم اسلحه من شرطه المحليه لانه ما في قوه
يعني تحميم
يحمي نفسه
هذا وفشلت الهدنه كما فشلت سابقاتها في
وقف اطلاق النار بين الطرفين نزاع
الاشتباكات تركزت في العاصمه الخرطوم
وتحديدا في محيط القصر الرئاسي ومناطقها
في محيط القياده العامه واداره المرافق
الاستراتيجيه التي تتعرض لقصف مدفعي وكذلك
المناطق المحيطه بمطار الخرطوم الدولي وحي
المطار السكني
ووفقا للجيش السوداني فان للشبكات تتركز
ايضا في مناطق في بحر وام درمان في هذه
الاثناء تحدث الجيش السوداني عن تحركات
كثيفه لارتال عسكريه للدعم السريع قادمه
من كردفان ودارفور وذلك لتعزيز قواتها
بالخرطوم كما اتهم الجيش ايضا قوات الدعم
السريع باستخدام المدنيين في الاحياء
السكنيه كدروع بشريه
نحن ما حنطلع
نموت في بيوتنا الموت واحد احنا اولادنا
يقوموا من الصباح عشان يجيبوا لنا مويه
لغايه بالليل مويه عشان نشرب نحن
حد وين يا حماتي يا اخي خافوا الله فينا
خافوا الله فينا لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين انتقل بكم الى كلمه
منذ قليل قالها المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه تدرس حول الازمه في السودان
نتابع ما قاله منذ قليل
good morning
نتحدث اولا عن السودان ان السبت الدماء
الذي شهدناه خلال الايام العشر الماضيه في
السودان
يحطم القلوب هذه الدوله التي يعاني فيها
شعبها اصلا وانا الكثير للسنوات القليله
الماضيه منظمه الصحه العالميه ترحب بوقت
اطلاق النار هذا اتفاق يتوصل عليه اهل
الطرفان ونحط كافه الاطراف على الالتزام
به بالكامل
ان العنف
اثر بشكل كبير على الصحه حلاوه على اعداد
الوفيات والاصابات الناجمه عن النزاع نفسه
فان منظمه الصحه العالميه تتوقع
والخدمات الصحيه من ضمنها اللقاحات او
تحسين
تقدر الصحه العالميه بان ربع الحيوانات
التي زهقت الان كان بالامكانه انقاذها مع
امكانيه الوصول
الى العنايه الطبيه الى ان الممرضين
والاطباء غير قادرين الوصول الى المدني
المصابين
والمصابين بدورهم غير قادرين الوصول الى
الخدمات في العاصمه الخرطوم
61% من المشاه الصحيه مغلقه
فقط سته عشر بالمئه تعمل في الوضع الطبيعي
عدد كبير من المصابين من اصحاب الامراض
المزمنه مثل امراض الكبد والسكري والسرطان
غير قادرين على الوصول الى المنشات الصحيه
او الحصول على الادويه التي هم بحاجه
اليها في الاسابيع المقبله
نقدر بان 24 الف ستلد الا ان هنا غير
قادره على الوصول الى الرعايه الان
حتى برامج لمنع
اضطرت ليتوقف ان مخاطر عالي جدا حيث تاثرت
معنا اللميع وبدا الاشخاص يشربون مياه
الانهار من اجل البقاء مع برامج
الغذاء
تدفع خمسون الف طفلا يواجهون مخاطر حقيقيه
كما ان حركه المدنيين الباحثين عن الماوى
الامن يؤثر على منظومه الصحيه عبر السودان
منذ اندلاع النزاع ومنظمه الصحه العالميه
تاكدت من 16 هجما على المشعه الصحيه
وتسببت بوفاه ثمانيه اشخاص منظمه الصحه
العالميه قليقه من
الاستيلائي على المركز الصحي المركزي من
قبل احد الطرفين والفنيين ما قادروا ما
عادوا قادرين على الوصول الى المختبر وهذا
يعني بانه غير قادر على ادائي واجباتي
ومهامي التشخيصيه نحن قلقون ايضا من هؤلاء
الذين استولى على المختبر ربما يتعرضون
بشكل غير متعمد على
العينات المخزونه فيه نحن نسعى للحصول
المجموعه ونقيم المخاطر
والقطعه الكهرباء تهدد بانما تبقى من
[موسيقى]
التبرعاتها منظمه الصحه العالميه
يجازف مضافها من اجل توفير الخدمات
لمن هم بحاجه ماسه اليها نحن نعيد تموقع
موظفينا
وعالاتهم من اجل سلامتهم ولكننا مستمرون
بالتخطيط لتقديم خدماتنا على افضل وجه
منظمه الصحه العالميه لديها مخزون من
الادويه
والتبرعاتيه بالدم
العمليات الجراحيه ولكننا بحاجه الى وصول
امن من اجل القيام بذلك
وكما هو الحال دائما فان افضل دواء في هذه
الحاله هو السلم
والان الى جائحه كوبي تسعه عشر في فبراير
عشرين اعزائي المشاهدين نكتفي بهذا بهذه
الكلمه التي قالها منذ قليل رئيس المنظمه
الصحه العالميه تدرس انهم حول الاوضاع في
السودان تحديدا الوضع الصحي في السودان
واحتمالات تفشي الامراض بطبيعه الحال وسط
انقطاع تام للكهرباء والمياه
وخطوره تفشي او مثل الكوليرا
والملاريا على كل نعود الى هذه التغطيه
حيث حملت قوات الدعم السريع المجتمع
الدولي مسؤوليته اتجاه خرق الهدنه من قبل
قيادات الجيش السوداني مشيره الى ان عدم
التزام قيادات الجيش بالهدنه تؤكد تعدد
مراكز القرار داخل الجيش كما اتهمت قوات
الدعم السريع قوات من الجيش بمهاجمه
مواقعها بمحيط القصر الجمهوري وارض
المعسكرات وسوبا في وقت واحد
هذا واظهرت الصور استمرار اغلاق المحال
التجاريه في السودان مع تواصل المواجهات
المسلحه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
يعني عندها يعني عشره
من جانبها عبرت بريطانيا عن قلقها ازاء
التقارير التي تفيد بان الطرفين اخفقان
مره اخرى بالوفاء بالتزاماتهما حول الهدنه
ودعت قوات الجيش والدعم السريع الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار وانهاء العنف بالاضافه
الى السماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه
وضمان حمايه المدنيين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني والطبي
من جانبه دع الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو دع الاطراف المتصارعه في السودان
الى وقف القتال في البلاد مشددا على ان
القتاله لن يكون حلا للصراع بين القوتين
دعا قاده السودان لجعل مصالح شعبهم اولويه
وان يقوموا باسكات اسلحتهم فورا
رشاش الدوشكا الروسي صمم في الثلاثينات من
القرن الماضي
السودان من الدول التي تستخدم هذا الرشاش
بكثره
طلقته كبيره الحجم من عيار 12.7 ملم
يصل مدرا رمي الى ثلاثه الاف وخمائه متر
في الاصل هو رشاش ثقيل مضاد للطائرات
يمكن استخدامه ضد المدرعات الخفيفه
والاليات العسكريه
اذا تم استخدامه في المناطق المدنيه سيؤدي
الى اضرار مروعه
من جنوب الخرطوم ينضم اليه المزيد من
المتابعه والتحليل الصحفي السوداني متدثر
محمد سيد مدثر اهلا وسهلا بك اولا هل يمكن
القول ان الهدنه سقطت تماما ام لا يعني ما
زالت قائمه وان بشكل هش
اليوم الاول هي لم تشهد لم تشهد التزاما
من جانب الطرفين
بحسب الاتهامات المتبادله وبحسب ما نشفته
على الميدان من الاشتباكات هنا وهناك
وعمليات القصف الجوي وعمليات القصف
المدفعي بين الطرفين ايضا كذلك الاتهامات
التي تقول بان الدعم السريع يتخذ من
التحركات الميداليه
يعني من الهدنه المجال للتحرك وكذلك الجيش
يقول ان
هذه القوات
تتحرك في انتشار الدعم السريع يقول ان
الجيش قد بدا بالقصف بقواته يعني هذه
الاتهامات المتبادله هي ديدنا الطرفين منذ
بدايه الهدى منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباكات ول
ذلك يشهد
الخرطوم في اليوم الاول وفي اليوم الثاني
هدوءا في الاوضاع فيما عدا بعض المنا
طق هذه هذه المناوشات بين الجانبين ولكن
كافه المناطق الحيويه التي يدور فيها
الصراع لم تتوقف فيها عمليات الاشتباك
هنا جنوب الخرطوم شهدت اليوم صباحا
عبر الطيران في منطقه سوق شرق
لمنطقه يعني توجد بها عدد من قوات الدعم
السريع تم قصفها صباح اليوم
بالطيران الجو او
بالسوداني كذلك شهدت منطقه جنوب الخرطوم
تحليق لطائرات السلاح الجو السوداني
وبعض الاشتباكات في محيط المدينه الرياضيه
وارض المعسكرات سوبا التي يتواجد بها ايضا
او يوجد بها معسكر للدعم السريع بخلاف هذه
الامتلافات في الصباح كما
تتابعون القياده شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه منذ
صباح اليوم ولا زالت مستمره حتى الان هذه
الاشتباكات بحسب بيان الجيش الذي قال انه
تعرض لهجوم في محيط القياده
حدثت هذه الاشتباكات ادت الى سقوط قذائف
عده في عدد من المناطق المحيطه في منطقه
شرق المطار وشرق القياده العامه منطقه
بوري ومنطقه الناصر تحدث الينا عدد من
السكان في هذه المناطق عن سقوط عدد من
القضاء في في القرب من المنازل والميادين
او بالقرب من
المناطق السكنيه ولكن لم ترد الينا او لم
يذكروا انه
قد سقط جراءها اي سكان او انها قد ادت الى
اصابات او
سيد مدثر
يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع السيد مدثر لنا
عوده اليه فرجوز الاتصال بالطبع يعني
نعاني من مشكله في الاتصالات
من مع السودان نتيجه الاوضاع الدراماتيكيه
في هذا البلد منذ بدء الاشتباكات
والمواجهات والمستمره من اثنين عشره يوما
على كل ايضا من الخرطوم ينضم اليه لمزيد
من المتابعه المحلل العسكري الفريق فتح
الرحمن محي الدين
سيد محي الدين هل تعتقد انه مع عدم
الالتزام بالهدنه فان الامور ذاهبه نحو
الاسوا في الايام القادمه
فريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين هل تسمعني
يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال ايضا كما قلت هنالك
مشكله
بالاتصالات على كل اعزائي المشاهدين في
اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء من السودان قال
مراسل العربيه ان نحو سبع طائرات عسكريه
تصل يوميا الى بورتسودان للاجلاء بالتنسيق
مع الجيش هذا وصلت احدى طائرات الاجلاء
الى بيروت بمساعده السعوديه محمله باثنين
وثلاثين شخصا
كما تمر عمليه الاجلاء الى ليبيا عبر ثلاث
مراحل بريه وجويه وبحريه تبدا بالانتقال
بالحافلات الى بورتسودان ثم الى ميناء جده
وصولا الى المحطه الاخيره في طرابلس
واستقبل مطار معيتيقه الدولي
105 من افراد الجاليه الليبيه في السودان
بعد اجلائهم
واكدت الجزائر ان 13 فلسطينيا واثنين
وعشرين سوريا وعددا اخر من الرعايه
بالخرطوم قدموا من مطار بورت سودان
استغلال استغلال ذاته بشر
يعني التذكره الصباح بسعر والنسبي سعر
الباص فضله خمسه مقاعد لكن
اليو خمسين
الان بدا النزول
الاشخاص على رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده
ونشاهد ايضا هذه السيده والتي ترافقها
احدى المجندات السعوديات من الحرس من حرس
الحدود وكذلك جون من حرس الحدود يرافقونها
في عمليه نزولهم وهي من الدفعه الاولى
طبعا الفئات المخصصه للاحتياجات الطبيه هم
يقومون به الان النزول والتوجه مباشره الى
مركبه الاسعاف كما نشاهد التي خصصتها
الصحه وهيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي وكذلك
السلطات السعوديه وتامين صحه وسلامه رعايه
بعثه الامم المتحده تحمل هذه الفرقاطه
قرابه ال400 شخص من جنسيات مختلفه هناك
السلك الدبلوماسي لعدد من الدول سواء
الدول من اوروبا وكذلك امريكا وهم ايضا
سوف يستقبلون بعض من بعثه الامم المتحده
يتواجدون الان هنا على الرصيف ميناء جده
الاسلامي هنا ايضا وصول او نزول ايضا
المزيد من بعثه الامم المتحده ورعايه
الامم المتحده الذين وصلوا
من شرق دارفور لمزيد من المتابعه الان
الصحفي صالح ابو علامه سيد صالح هلا وسهلا
بك كيف هي الاوضاع في شرق دارفور هل
الاوضاع مستقره هل هنالك التزام تام
بالهدنه ام لا الاوضاع لا تطمئن ولا تبشر
بالخير ان صح التعبير
نعم
تماما شهدت غربي
ثلاث ايام هذا هو اليوم الثالث حفظت
المعارك بحسب
الاحصاءات الاوليه سته وتسعين قتيل من
الطرفين حتى الان ونقصد هنا بالطرفين لان
العراق في
غرب دارتور في الشرق دارفور في غرب تحول
من صراع بين الدعم السريع والجيش الى صراع
بين القبائل في غرب ديرفور في الجنينه
الحصيله الاوليه كما قلنا 96 كفيل
110 جريحه الان بين الطرفين القبائل
العربيه اصدرت بيان اليوم
وعظمه فيه
بوقت اطلاق النار وطلبت الجهاز الحكوميه
بالوقوف مسافه واحده من الطرفين وايضا
يعني قبيله المساليد اصدرت بيان وقالت فيه
بان هنالك طرف ثالث في هذه المعرفه وتسائل
وتسائل البيان عن كيفيه تحول الصراع من
صراع بين الجيش والدعم السريع الى صراع
بين القبائل لان الاشتباكات كانت تدور في
منطقه معينه وفجاه تحولت الى مكان اخر مما
يعني خلف نزوح كبير في المواطنين واثار
للحرق والدمار
لاربعه احياء
ومعسكرين للناجحين
الجنينه الوضع ماذا يعني لم يسيطر عليه
تماما
الجرحى يعني ماذا لو
لا يمكن الوصول الى بعض منهم وهنالك ايضا
قتل لا تستطيع
الجهات الوصول الى مكارهم ومما فارغم
الازمه اكثر هو حرف مبنى الهلال الاحمر
يوم امس وكل هذه الاشياء ساهمت مساهمه
كبيره في اتفاقم الوضع في غربي دارفور
فقط في مدينه الجنينه ام في مناطق ومدن
اخرى سيد صالح
وعندما نقول صراع بين القبائل عن اي قبائل
نتحدث يعني اي قبيله ضد اي قبيله فقط
لنعطي فكره للمشاهدين
في الديانه ينشا بين سلطنه مساليه
والقبائل العربيه هذا هو المسمى الموجود
قبيله المساليس هي قليله كبيره ومعروفه في
دارفور معروفه في بنينه
في غرب جنينه وايضا هنا تجمع كبير للقبائل
العربيه هكذا
يسمونه اسمهم
اذا طلعنا اليوم بيانين بيان للمساليد
وبيان لتجمع القبائل العربيه بغربي اذا
طرفيه عن قبائل العربيه
والمساليد طب ايه بس صالح لنوضح من مع
قوات الجيش ومع ومن مع قوات الدعم السريع
هل للامور واضحه ام لا يعني
هذه المواجهات
لا علاقه لها مباشره بما يجري بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع هذه ارهاصات سابقه
ويعني ماضيه يعني منذ ردح من الزمن والان
تتفاقم وتنفجر
نعم هذه المشكله او هذا الصراع هو
الاحتفال الموجود في مجتمع دارفور الجنينه
يعني مدينه مثل الجنينه
حتما في القوات المسلحه هنالك ابناء
المساليد وابناء القبائل العربيه وفي دعم
السريعه ايضا هنالك ابناء المساليد وابناء
القبائل العربيه احيانا في مثل هذه
الاحداث يعني
ينطلق بعض
المجندين في صفوف القوات المسلحه الدعم
السريع
وينتمون مباشره الى قبائلهم لذا يعني يكون
في اطلاع بهذه الطريقه وهذا يعني بعد ما
وردنا ان حدث يعني انطلاق لبعض المجموعات
التي تنتمي بعضها ينتمي الى الدعم السريع
بعضها ينتمي الى القوات المسلحه ودخلوا مع
قبائلهم
وتتفاهم هذا الصراع بهذه الكيفيه طرف اخر
ايضا دخل في صراعه في الجنينه هي قوات
التحالف السوداني وهذا التحالف السوداني
هي حركه يدعى لها والي ولايه تغرب
الجنينه ايضا يعني في هنالك اشارات لان
حركه التحالف السوداني دخلت في في هذا
الصراع وهي ايضا جزء من مكونات مدينه
جنينه بغربي دارفور سيد صالح حل المواجهات
والاقتتال مقتصر على مدينه الجنينه
ام لا هنالك خشيه كبيره من ان يتوسع هذا
القتال ليطال مدن اخرى وليس فقط في غرب
دارفور وانما قد يصل الى شرق دارفور
نعم في شرق دارفور يعني
الاداره الاهليه
ميثاق توافق عليه الجميع الدعم السريع
بان لا يكون عراسي هذه المنطقه وينتظر ما
تؤول اليه الاوضاع في الخرطوب ما تؤول
اليه الاحداث الجاريه الان في الخرطوم نعم
تتاثر ولايات دارفور لكل شيء يدور في في
ولايه اخرى المجتمعات متداخله
والمكونات التي توجد في دارفور توجد
في جنوب دارفور لكن الاوضاع ما زالت تحت
السيطره يعني ولم تمتلك في في
جنوب دارفور وفي الشمال دارفور لم تملي
مثل ما هو الان في في الجنينه الاحداث في
الجنينه اخذت صانع قبليه الاحداث في جنوب
دارفور لم تاخذ طابعه وانما صراع بين
الدعم والجيش في مناوشات على السيطره على
القياده ومستمره منذ اليوم الاول
للمعارك ولكن الخشيه من تحول الصراع الى
صراع قبلي كانت في محلها
وحصل ما لا يحمد عقباه تحديدا في الجنينه
اليس كذلك
نعم نعم حصل ما لا يقدر عقبه تحديدا في
الجنينه يعني هذا هذا القتال لثلاثه ايام
وخلف يعني اثار كبيره جدا نزوح كبير جدا
نحو
المتاخمه التي تربطها حدود الدوله
لولايه غريب ديرفور الجنينه كبير
للمواطنين يعني هنالك مخاوف ايضا هذه
النزوح يواجه ايضا بعراق في الطريق لانه
الطريق الذي يعني يسلكه النازحون به ايضا
القبائل العربيه وبه المثاليه وهكذا
من شرق دارفور الصحفي صالح ابو عالمه شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
يعني هو الرعب الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك عم
تقصف يعني رعب كان فظيع من تبغى تصير
مذيعه يا محمد معانا
يعني رعب نفسي وجسدي
والله كنا بالسودان بالعاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطوم نفسها الخرطوم نفسه وكان في يعني
نسمع اصوات تقريبا كذا واخر فتره لما
قللنا انه خلص بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي
جدا يعني
منظم ما شاء الله وكان كذا في جنود وكلهم
قاعدين يعطونا ترتيبات يعني فكان الموضوع
جدا سهل الحمد لله وصلتوا مع السفاره
السعوديه هنا ايوه اهلي من هنا تواصلوا
معاهم قالوهم قالوا لهم نروح على الميناء
البري البحري
في هذه الاثناء واكبت كاميرا العربيه وصول
البارجات والقطع البحريه لمختلف الدول فور
وصولها الى ميناء بورسودان حيث وثقت
العربيه وصول قطعه بحريه هنديه الى
الميناء من اجل نقل الجاليه الهنديه
واجلائها من هنا في احد المراسي هنا في
مدينه بورسودان تحديدا في الميناء الاخضر
بالميناء الشمالي
باخره او قطعتان حربيتان بحريتان ووصلتا
صباح هذا اليوم الى ميناء بورسودان
يتبعاني لدوله الصين
يستعدان لاجلاء نحو 600 من رعايه الصين
هنا في بورسودان وصلوا خلال اليومين
الماضيين اما هنا فهذه القطع البحريه
العسكريه الهنديه ايضا قبل قليل اكتملت
كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه بالدخول الرعايه
دوله الهند في اطار مراحل مختلفه
تعلم بان عدد الجاليه الهنديه في السودان
يقدر بنحو 4000
هذا وصلت اول طائره اجلاء تابعه للخطوط
الملكيه المغربيه الى مطار محمد الخامس
الدوري في مدينه الدار البيضاء
[موسيقى]
اما على الحدود بين مصر والسودان فاصبح
معبر ارقيين البريه الفاصل بين البلدين
بمثابه طوق نجاه الفري من هذه الشبكات حيث
عبر من خلاله ما لا يقل عن 5000 شخص خلال
الايام القليله الماضي
معبر ارجين البري يفصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه افتتحس سبتمبر عام 2016 لنقل
البضائع والركاب يقع على مسافه 850
كيلومترا شمالي الخرطوم يستوعب سبعه الاف
وخمسمائه مسافر يوميا واكثر من ثلاثمائه
شاحنه بات يمثل طوق نجاه للفرين من
اشتباكات السودان عبر منه الالاف من
السودانيين والمصريين هربا من القتال بعد
اجتياز المعبر يتجه المسافرون الى مدينه
اسوان الوصول اليه يتطلب رحله محفوفه
بالمتاعب تستغرق نصف يوم للوصول اليه من
الخرطوم ومده مماثله للعبور الى اسوان
ونظرا لصعوبه الوضع في السودان سمح
للسودانيين بعبوره بلا تاشيره مسبقه
معي من معبر ارجين على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان والذي
انتقل من القاهره الى هناك لمتابعه هذه
الاوضاع احمد اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد
من عندك وابرز مشاهداتك اليوم احمد
نعم اهلا بك طالب بالفعل هناك يعني عن
استمرار لعمليه خروج المصريين والسودانيين
والاجانب من معبر ارجين يتوجهون الى مدينه
اسوان يعني احدث الاحصائيات التي تتعلق
بالارقام خلال الساعات الماضيه بان معبر
ارجين تم خروج منه اكثر من 800 الف شخص ما
بين مصريين وسودانيين واجانب اكثر بكثير
من المعبر البري الاخر وهو معبر قسطا هناك
ايضا استمرار لعمليه يعني اجلاء للمصريين
العالقين في مدينه الخرطوم عبر الطائرات
العسكريه طائرتين عسكريتين تتوجهان يوميا
الى مدينه الخرطوم لاجلاء المصريين الذين
ربما يعانون من مشاكل في الوصول الى
المنافذ الحدوديه البريه نتيجه للظروف
ربما المشهد الابرز اليوم هو المتعلق
بالتاخير في خروج البعض بحسب ما تحدثنا مع
الناس هناك الكثير
جانب السوداني من المعبر وايضا استمرار
عمليات التفتيش هذا قد فسر بانه يعني ربما
لم يكن في بحيره احد ان يكون هذا التكدس
الكبير لهذا المعبر هذا النزوح الكبير
للفرين من جحيم ما يحدث في السودان وهو ما
يستدعي موازنه دقيقه جدا تقوم بها السلطات
المصريه ما بين محاوله تقديم المساعدات
الطبيه والتسهيلات وبغيرها وايضا التاكد
من سلامه بكل من يدخل سواء فيما يتعلق
بالعناصر البشريه لضمان عدم وجود اي تسلل
لعناصر ارهابيه وايضا مساله تفتيش البضائع
من خلال الحافلات وهذا ربما هذه النقطه هي
فكره الحافلات التي تنقل المسافرين من
الجانب الى الاخر هذه الترتيبات تاخذ
كثيرا من الوقت وهيئه الموانئ المصريه
اكدت بانه قد يكون هناك تعيين لمزيد من
الموظفين للمحاوله للاصراع من وتيره خروج
العالقين من الجانب السوداني الى الجانب
المصري كما ذكرت بالفعل او كما جاء في
التقرير يتم بعد ذلك الانتقال الى مدينه
اسوان يعني اقرب مدينه من حيث اقف الان هي
على بعد اكثر من 400 كلم حافلات تنقل
المواطنين الذين يخرجون في رحله قد تستغرق
حوالي خمس ساعات او اكثر هناك من يتوجهون
الى بعض الى القاهره مباشره وهناك من
يمكثون في اسوان وهناك ايضا عدد من
الاجانب الذين يتم التعامل من خلال
سفاراتهم وملحقياتهم الذين ينتقلون من هذه
من هذا المكان الى القاهره للتوجه الى
بلدانهم من خلال مطار القاهره الدولي طيب
احمد
انظر معي اذا هذا المشهد يعني المعلومات
الوارده من الحدود التشاديه السودانيه
تقول ان اوضاع من نزح من السودان الى تشاد
اوضاعهم مدريه للاسف هنا الباء الكثير
منهم يعاني من الامراض من سوء التغذيه الى
ما هنالك الذين يصلون الى معبر ارجين يعني
كيف يمكن وصف
الحاله حالتهم
هل تقدم لهم مباشره المساعدات سواء
الغذائيه او الطبيه ام ماذا وفق مشاهداتك
وعلى ماذا عن ماذا يتحدثون
انا اتحدث من خارج البوابه الرئيسيه
للمعبر لكن بحسب ما علمنا بان هناك مركز
اغاثه وقت كثير من السيارات اسعاف
والتيارات واسره وتوضعت داخل المعبر
للتعامل مع اي اصابات مع القادمين من
السودان يعني من اتحدث معهم هم من تجاوزوا
هذه المرحله والذين نتحدث معهم لمده دقائق
قبل ان
يتجهوا الى الحافلات للانطلاق الى مدينه
اسوان والى غيرها من المدن المصريه ولكن
عوده لسؤالك ما يعني ابرز ما شاهدته من
خلال حوارات مع من يخرجون من البعبر
ويتوجهون الى الحافلات هم يتحدثون ربما عن
اصابات نفسيه اكثر ما هي امراض لها علاقه
بالبدن يعني الكل يتحدث بنوع من الحزن
الشديد الغضب الشديد القهر الشديد القلق
الشديد عن ما تركه خلفه في السودان القلق
عن ما هو قادم هل سيعودون مره اخرى كثير
منهم يحملون حقائب صغيره بعض الناس تحدثوا
ب بما عليهم من ملابس بعض الناس يتحدثون
ربما عن هناك يعني ليس لديهم الاموال
ليحددوا كم سيجلسون في مصر الفتره المقبله
ولهذا ربما هذا ما يفسر بان هناك التوجه
الابرز الى مدينه اسوان مدينه اسوان هي
قريبه العادات من اهل شمال السودان ويجدون
فيها نوع من الراحه النفسيه وبالتالي ايضا
فيما يتعلق بانها تعتبر اقل كلفه في
الاقامه اكثر منها من العاصمه او المدن
الكبيره الاخرى ولكن هناك نوع من القلق عن
ما حدث وعدم تفسير له يعني لماذا كل هذا
لهذا المشهد هذا النزوح الكبير ويعني ما
يتركون وراءهم الكثير من الامور يعني هو
هربا من الخوف وبالتالي الشعور الاخر هو
القلق عن ما هو قادم هذه هي ابرز المشاهد
التي لفتت نظري خلال الساعات الماضيه من
خلال حديثي مع من عبر الحدود ووصل الى مصر
طيب احمد انت تتحدث الخارجيه المصريه تؤكد
اعاده تمركز البعثه المصريه اعاده تمركز
البعثه المصريه في السودان في موقع اخر مع
تزايد التهديدات هل من معلومات اضافيه
وصلاتك او يعني كانت متوفر لديك حول هذا
الموضوع وهل هذا المركز الجديد الذي تتحدث
عنه الخارجيه المصريه هو داخل ارخطوم او
خارج الخرطوم او ربما خارج السودان
يعني نتحدث عن هذا الخبر بان هناك يعني
السفاره المصريه التي ابوابها ما زالت
مفتوحه وتعمل منذ بدايه الازمه في الخرطوم
نتحدث ايضا عن القنصليه ونتحدث عن مكتب
عمل
لوادي حلفا يعني اقرب نقطه الى السودان
السفاره تعمل هناك والقنصليه المصريه
يعملون هناك علاقات من وساق منذ بدايه
الازمه اولا لتامين اجلاء المصريين وايضا
اجلاء ايضا لمساله تامين اجلاء السودانيين
الذين يخرجون الى مصر وبالتالي كان هناك
يعني عدد من الحوادث التي حدثت خلال
الفتره الماضيه هناك اصابات وضحايا من قبل
المصريين هناك سقوط قتل مساعد القنصل
الاداري المصري كل هذه المشاهد تثقل من
العمل على السفاره ربما تبقى النقطه
الاخيره وهو المتعلق باللغط في فكره
التاشيرات يعني تعرف ان العلاقه المصريه
او او قانون الحريات الاربعه الذي بموجبه
يتم تبادل السلع والبضائع البشر الذين
يدخلون على المنافذ هناك بعض التعديلات
عليهم بعض النقطه الاخيره بانه هذه النقطه
بان هناك بعض الاشاعات التي تتعلق بانه قد
تذهب الى تذهب الى المعبر دون الحصول على
تاشيره قد تدخل من هناك هذه النقطه ما زال
فيها نوع من اللغات يجب ان يكون هناك حصول
على التاشيرات خصوصا لمن هم دول الخمسين
عاما من معبر ارجين على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان دائما
شكرا جزيلا لك احمد على كل هذه المتابعه
وفي تداعيات الازمه الصحيه المتفاقمه جراء
الاشتباكات المستمره قالت نقابه اطباء
السودان في بيانها اليومي ان عدد الوفيات
بين المدنيين ارتفع الى 295 حاله وفاه
بينما تم تسجيل الف وسبعمائه وتسعين حاله
اصابه بين المدنيين منذ بدايه هذه
الاشتباكات
ومع استمرار المواجهات يتفاقم الوضع
الانساني وصعوبات المعيشه كما تزداد
المخاوف من شبح الجوع والعطش وشلل حركه
التنقل
مواد السودانيين مع وقف النهائي للقتال
يبقى مؤجلا وكافه الرصاص لا تزال هي
الارجح على الاقل حتى الان المشهد في
العاصمه يبدو مخيفا محل اقفلها اصحابها
بعد نفاذ المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه منها
وتوقف اسواق الجمله عن العمل ومحل البقاله
القليله التي لا تزال تعمل تكاد تخلو من
البضائع والمتوفر منها تفوق اسعاره قدره
المواطن العادي يعني بكل جهاد لا كهرباء
ولا
يمكن
زي ما انت شايف
اربعين دقيقه بين اربعين الى ستين دقيقه
عشان
عشر عشرين عيشه
الحمد لله
حامدون وشاكرون رغم قسوه الصراع والاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه
في استغلال يعني حتى لو الباب بتاع
الدقيقه الليله ب 8000 هيديك له قريبا من
محله بالف جنيه
والسيارات هذه وكانها بلا نهايه في ام
درمان تصطفوا الى جانب محطات الوقود رغم
يقين اصحابها بخلو تلك الخزانات من اي
وقود ولو توفرت فالاسعار المطلوبه غير
متوفره
ازمات السودانيين تتضاعف مع الانقطاع
المتكرري لخدمات الانترنت والاتصالات
الهاتفيه فضلا عن شرح السيوله النقديه
واغلاق البنوك لتبقى اصوات الرصاص
المتقطعه في هدنه هشه لتزيد مخاوف
السودانيين من اطاله امد الصراع حنان
المصري العربيه
الى القاهره الان تنضم الي لمزيد من
المتابعه المتحدثه الاعلاميه ومديره
الوحده الاقليميه للاعلام في برنامج
الغذاء العالميه السيده عبير عطيفه ست
عبير اهلا وسهلا بك
اي تقييم يمكن اعطائه للاوضاع الانسانيه
في السودان بعد 12 يوما من الاقتتال
تحديدا موضوع سلاسل الغذاء وما هي مخاوفكم
طبعا شعب السودان بحاجه ماسه الى وقفه
انسانيه هناك كما ذكر التقرير
يعني نقص شديد في المواد الغذائيه في كثير
من المناطق في السودان وتوقف كلي لعمليه
سلاسه الامداد فيما يخص بالمواد الغذائيه
طبعا
يجب ان يكون الناس قادرين على الوصول الى
الغذاء والوقود والادويه وغيرها من
الامدادات والخدمات الحيويه ولكن للاسف
الوضع الحالي في
انحاء متفرقه من السودان يعني ينذر بان
انا على يعني فقط اسف للمقاطعه عبير
اعزائي المشاهدين لاشير في هذا الخبر
العاجل وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان يؤكد ان
الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان اكد لسلفاكير
موافقته على لقاح متي خارج الخرطوم اذا
وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان دوله جنوب
السوداني يؤكد ان الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان قائد الجيش يؤكد لرئيس جنوب
السودان سلفاكير موافقته على لقاء الجنرال
حميد خارج الخرطوم ست عبير تفضل اكمل
يعني حتى قبل هذه الاحداث التي بدات في
السودان منذ ما يقرب من عشره ايام كانت
الاحتياجات الانسانيه بالفعل في اعلى
مستويات على الاطلاق ثلث سكان السودان وهو
عدد كبير حوالي 15 مليون شخص يحتاج الى
مساعدات انسانيه
ويعاني منع يقل عن اربعه ملايين طفل
وامراه حامل من سوء التغذيه الحاد
بالاضافه طبعا عمليات النزوح الداخليه
طبعا نحن في برنامج العالمي بنشعر
الحقيقه فزع وحزن من طبعا تعليق مساعدتنا
وقفه عمليات المساعدات الغذائيه في داخل
السودان بسبب طبعا مقتل ثلاثه من موظفي
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في اعمال العنف
التي اندلعت في شمال دارفور في 15 ابريل
ايضا قتلت في الحادث اربعه من موظفي بنك
النيل الازرق وتم التعليق جميع عمليات
خدمات النقل الجوي في جميع انحاء البلاد
بسبب اجتياح ونهب المكاتب والمستودعات
والدمار الذي شمل طائرات برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي وطائرات الامم المتحده التي كانت
موجوده في مطار الخرطوم وبالتالي كيف لنا
ان نساعد وان نلتزم بمساعده الناس في
السودان الذين يواجهون انعدام شديد في
الامن الغذائي ولكن عمليه القيام بهذا
العمل المهم صعبه جدا اذا لم يتم ضمان
سلامه وامن جميع الفرق المساعدات
الانسانيه في داخل البلاد ست عبير في حديث
يتواتر عن مجاعه قادمه في السودان بفعل
استمرار الاقتتال هل هذا الحديث في محله
ولهما يؤكده ويبرره ام لا هذه المبالغات
يعني ليس هي ليست بالمبالغات لان طبعا
بالفعل كما ذكرت خمسه عشر مليون شخص في
السودان بيحتاجه للمساعدات الانسانيه
والمساعدات الغذائيه وبالتالي يعني وهذا
حتى كان قبل اندلاع احداث العنف وقبل اي
مشاكل تواجه السودان
فما بالك اليوم
بالوضع الانساني للشعب السوداني مهجرين
نقص في الامدادات الغذائيه نقصف في الوقود
انقطاع في شبكات يعني التواصل كل هذا اكيد
طبعا سيؤدي الى دخول السودان في نفق مظلم
على جميع الاصعده بما في ذلك مجال الامن
الغذائي التعبير بتعرفي يعني في شحب
المصادر المستقله لمعرفه حقيقه ما يجري
كمان اليوم في تقارير وحديث عن بدء انتشار
اوبئه وامراض في الخرطوم
في ضوء القطاع المياه والكهرباء حديث عن
كوليرا ملاريا هل تصلكم اي معلومات من من
هذا القبيل ام لا يعني كمان هذه المعلومات
يعني لا يمكن ان اكون اليها
هو طبعا يعني
صعب يعني القيام بعمليه يعني عندما تحدث
ازمه مثل هذا
الخطوات المتبعه هي ان يقوم هناك تقييم
للوضع في على ارض الواقع ولكن في ظل هذا
يعني الوضع الامني المتدهور في ظل طبعا
الظروف الصعبه التي يعيشها موظفي البرنامج
الاغذيه العالمي بالاضافه ايضا الى كل
موظفين الاغاثه صعب جدا الحصول على يعني
صوره صحيحه وحقيقيه للارض على الوقت ولكن
ليس بمستبعد نحن نعلم ماذا تاتي الحروب
واثارها المدمره على الاشخاص وعلى الناس
سواء كان هذا من انتشار الاوبئه نقص
المياه نقص الغذاء يعني هي هي حلقه مفرغه
الجوع يؤدي الى الصراعات المسلحه والعنف
والعنف ايضا يولد اعداد مهوله من الجوعه
واول مرضى والاوبئه وبالتالي يعني اعتقد
منظمه الصحه العالميه ذكرت ان هناك طبعا
خطر من دخول البلاد الى هذه الى دائره
الاوبئه
هذه المستودعات وعدم ضمان يعني
مناطق وممرات انسانيه تسمح
للموظفي البرنامج بالتوزيع الامن لهذه
المواد الغذائيه وتامين الموظفين وتامين
ايضا الافراد الذين يعني يحتاجون الى هذه
المساعدات طبعا سيكون صعب جدا الوصول باي
نوع من المساعدات الى من يستحقها
والى يعني من يحتاجها بالاضافه الى هذا
طبعا يعني انا كما ذكرت هناك عدد من
طائرات البرنامج يعني
فيها خسائر كبيره نهب عشرات من السيارات
ان تؤمن اليه توزيع مواد غذائيه في
ظل هذه يعني
في ظل غياب اهم عنصر وهو عنصر الامن ست
عبير سؤال اخير هل لديكم اي اتصال مباشر
مع طرفي النزاع يعني الجيش السوداني ممثلا
بالفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان وقوات الدعم
السريع ممثله بالجنرال حميدتي هل لديكم اي
اتصالات مباشره
اتصال مباشر طواقم برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
نازله كثير منهم في داخل السودان لكن لست
اعلم اذا كان هناك اتصال مع
القيادات في داخل السودان من القاهره عبير
عطيفه المتحدثه الاعلاميه ومديره الوحده
الاقليميه للاعلام في برنامج الغذاء
العالمي شكرا
جزيلا لك
الان ينضم الي من مطار ستانس براسل
العربيه مصطفى زاروا في بريطانيا تحديدا
للحديث عن اجلاء بريطانيا
لراعيها من السودان مصطفى اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد من عندك وابرز مشاهداتك في
هذه الاوقات
اول طائره مدنيه حطت في مطار ستانستيد على
شمالي قبل تقريبا ساعتين من الان هناك
حافلتان
تم استخدامهما لنقل
يعني من تم اجلائهم ويعني هناك العديد من
الاسر
لهؤلاء
من تم اجلائهم من سودانيين ينتظرونهم
العديد منهم غادروا الى بيوتهم وكانوا جد
يعني سعداء بالعوده الى المملكه المتحده
لكنهم قلقين جدا بسبب الاوضاع الامنيه
المترديه طوال هذه الايام التي
تابعنا وشاهدنا
الاعمال العلف المتواصله دون توقف كانت
هناك هدى لكن دائما ما يقولون بان يتم
خرقه ويصنعون ذوي
يعني القصف وبالتالي كان جد مقلق وكان حتى
في بعض الاحيان من الصعب التواصل مع اهلهم
هنا في المملكه المتحده بسبب الانقطاع من
حين الاخر للكهرباء وايضا انقطاع الانترنت
وبالتالي على كل حال هم سعداء وهؤلاء يعني
جزء من هؤلاء الذين تم وصلوا قبل لحظات
ترونهم بامتعتهم العديد من هؤلاء الاسر
يعني بعضهم يعني عادوا يعني بجميع اعضاء
اسرهم ولكن هناك من يعني لا يزال ينتظر
يعني المجيء الى المملكه المتحده بانتظار
استكمال يعني لديهم ظروف شخصيه وبالتالي
هذا ربما يعني قلق متواصل لهؤلاء الذين
وصلوا تركوا البلد السودان في وضع جد
متازم لا يعرفون متى سيتم وقف عمليه
الاطلاق
بشكل مستمر والمضي الى حكومه ديمقراطيه
مدنيه مستقره بالطبع الحكومه الان تلقت
العديد من الانتقادات لانها لم تتحرك
بشكل سريع لاجلاء المحاصرين البريطانيين
وبالتالي ربما هذه هذه المشاهد فرح
لاولئك الذين كانوا ينتظرون الوصول يعني
الى الاراضي البريطانيه ولكن بالطبع لا
تزال هناك العديد من الرحلات لنقل
المحاصيل
من الرعايه البريطانيين يعني داخل السودان
ومصير البعثه البريطانيه في السودان هل
عرف
البعثه السودانيه هناك بحسب وزاره
الخارجيه هناك ما يقار من الف شخص من
افراد الجيش البريطاني يديرون حاليا
المطار العسكري في وادي سيدنا وبالتالي
بريطانيا الان هي التي تتسيد وتدير عمليات
الاجلاء
والرحلات الطيران العسكريه من من هذا
المطار العسكري
بالنسبه لاعداد المواطنين البريطانيين
وزاره الخارجيه اكدت بانها تواصلت مع يعني
اكثر بقليل من الف مواطن بريطاني ولكن
التقديرات تشير الى ان هناك ما يقارب من
4000 بريطاني حاليا هناك هناك
ساكتفي بهذا القدر لن اعود اليك في نشرات
او في تغطيات لاحقه للشان السوداني من
مطار ستانشد مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي تداعيات هروب عدد من رموز النظام
السابق من سجن كوبر بالعاصمه الخرطوم اكد
الجيش السوداني ان الرئيس السابق عمر حسن
البشير ما يزال محتجزا بمستشفى عسكري تحت
حراسه الشرطه القضائيه وقال الجيش في بيان
له ان البشير وعددا من قيادات حزبه
محتجزون في مستشفى علياء العسكري الجيش
عبر عن رفضه لاي محاولات لربط ما يجري في
السجون بمزايدات على مواقفه الوطنيه ووصف
الجيش السوداني الدعم السريع وقائده بانه
امتداد للنظام السابق
اما الشرطه السودانيه فحملت قوات الدعم
السريع مسؤوليه اطلاق سراح السجناء
بالاضافه الى الجرائم المرتكبه بحق
المواطنين واكدت الشرطه ان الدعم السريع
اطلق سراحا النزلاء في سته سجون بالخرطوم
والولايات الاخرى الشرطه قالت ايضا ان
قوات الدعم السريعه اقتحمت سجن كوبر
وتسببت في قتل وجرح عدد من قوات الشرطه
ما موقف اطراف الصراع في السودان من خروج
رموز نظام البشير من السجن
الجيش السوداني سلطه اداره السجون خارج
نطاق اختصاصنا وتحت مسؤوليه وزاره
الداخليه
الدعم السريع لا سيطره لدينا على السجون
في السودان وهذه مسؤوليه الشرطه
الميليشيات المتمرده اجبرت شرطه السجون
على اطلاق سراح النزلاء قيادات المواليه
للبشير في الجيش هي المسؤوله عن اطلاق
سراحه
اداره سجن كوبر اطلقت سراح نزلائه بسبب
انقطاع المياه والكهرباء والاعاشه خروج
قيادات البشير من سجن كوبر صدمه وانتكاسه
للشعب السوداني نحن غير معنيين باي بيانات
من اي جماعه او افراد خرجوا من السجون
مغادره قيادات النظام البشير للسجن امر
متوقع وبعضهم يطلبون دوليا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات